gilbert collard bonjour puis bonjour
merci d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans la matinale de rtl france alors on
le disait jean castex a donc annoncé
hier un durcissement des peines
encourues par les agresseurs de
policiers ou gendarmes après le meurtre
d'un brigadier la semaine dernière à
avignon la peine de sûreté pour les
personnes condamnées à perpétuité pour
un crime commis contre un policier ou un
gendarme seront portées à 30 ans avec
des policiers des possibilités de
réduction des peines strictement
limitées notamment
alors est-ce que vous saluer cette
réponse de l'exécutif ce matin quand on
prend l'eau le code pénal on est effrayé
par la sévérité des peines qui pourrait
être prononcé jeudi bien qu'ils
pourraient être prononcées et on est
consterné par le constat que jamais
jamais ces peines sont prononcés alors
ce qui compte c'est pas la surenchère
pénale la surenchère dans l'échelle des
peines que l'on ne prononce pas ce qui
compte si on veut en 10 17 criminalité
folle soudaine souvent même
incompréhensible c'est l'efficacité
immédiate de la peine je vous invite à
lire le code pénal vous verrez les
peines existe ce qui manque c'est le
prononcer immédiat de la peine marine le
pen a fait une proposition elle va la
faire mais elle en a déjà parlé qui me
paraît très efficace elle souhaite que
chaque fois qu'une infraction de
violences d' outrage d'agression
physique est commise contre un policier
le juge et l'obligation au moment où il
prononce la peine de décréter mandat de
dépôt -c'est-à-dire incarcération
immédiate
sauf motivation expresse tirer des
circonstances de la cause ou de la
personnalité
pour éviter ce mandat de dépôt de
manière que toutes les peine trois mois
six mois un an soit immédiatement
exécutés
même s'il ya appel même s'il y a appelle
pour donner un caractère d'effectivité
d'efficacité à la peine et qu'on ait pas
me dire mais ça n'est pas
constitutionnelle c'est tout à fait
constitutionnelle puisque le juge peut
par un attendu écarté cette disposition
s'ils considèrent qu'il y a des éléments
précis dans là dedans pendant le dossier
dans la personnalité qui permettrait de
ne pas ordonner le mandat de dépôt il
faut une réponse pénale immédiate
alors prenez vous avez vous avez des
outrages qui sont qui sont frappés d'une
peine de 3 mois de prison
le délinquant fait appel il est jugé
deux ans après ça signifie quoi
et pendant tout ce temps là il est libre
il fait ce qu'il veut il continue à
outrager non il faut une effectivité de
la peine
et alors là les policiers qui demande
aussi depuis longtemps plus donc de
fermeté de la justice notamment aussi
pour les délinquants récidivistes
vous qui avez été avocat pénaliste
est-ce que vous avez effectivement je
suis vous qui êtes avocat pénaliste
pardonnez moi est ce que vous avez
observé vous observez au fil des années
une justice qui devient de plus en plus
clémente dans ces sites dans ses
décisions et comment vous l'expliquez
riez on a une justice sociologique
on n'a plus une justice de l'application
du droit ce qui est la garantie
essentielle d'une démocratie judiciaire
on a une justice qui est contaminée par
la sociologie c'est à dire que on a une
approche qui est complètement
environnementale sociologique hugolienne
et qui ne tient pas compte de ce que la
loi veut le juge doit appliquer la loi
dans la proportion évidemment de de sa
de sa liberté de décision d'appréciation
mais il ya une véritable contamination
sociologique de la décision judiciaire
ce qui fait que on perd de vue la
victime
il faudrait aussi une sociologie de la
victime alors on parle beaucoup de
victimologie on s'intéresse aux victimes
mais la victime
dont elle a besoin c'est que le
délinquant le criminel soient punis et
elle a besoin de l'immédiateté de la
signification pénale il y avait un grand
criminologue gabriel tarde à qui disait
que lorsque le crime ne sera plus flétri
les criminels pulluleront mais c'est ça
aujourd'hui un autre à les outrages ne
sont pas poursuivis
les syndicalistes de police ne le disent
tous ont ils ne déposent même plus
plainte pour outrage tellement ils ont
la certitude que il n'y aura pas de
poursuites non je le répète encore une
fois ce qu'il faut c'est l'effectivité
l'immédiateté de la pelle et la
proposition que marine le pen portera
est à mon avis la seule solution pour
apporter une réponse pénale immédiate
mais il y a une vingtaine
il ya une vingtaine d'années par exemple
qu'on vous plaît dit est ce que la
justice était plus faible qu'aujourd'hui
ah oui oui n'était plus elle n'était pas
sociologique elle était juridique bien
sûr avec la prise en compte de la
personnalité avec la prise en compte de
l'environnement avec la prise en compte
de ce qu'on appelait à l'époque ça
n'existe plus maintenant les
circonstances atténuantes mais il y
avait une sévérité de la loi
vous comprenez c'est la loi qu'on
respecte plus dans les tribunes
aujourd'hui au motif de sang
l'interprétation au motif d des éléments
contextuels sociologique il le faut bien
évidemment il le faut aussi mais la loi
doit être appliquée je vous le dis
encore une fois si on avait le temps
prendrait le code pénal
on le lire être une minute vous vous
rendrez compte que les dden existent
mais elles ne sont pas prononcés voilà
et elle surtout elle tarde quand elles
le sont à l'être et quand elles le sont
elles ne sont pas exécutées faute de
place dans les prisons quand vous pensez
que un individu trafiquants de drogue a
été libéré récemment parce qu'on n'avait
pas le personnel pour l'accompagner au
tribunal
tout est dit tout est dit le reste c'est
du cinéma
alors le premier ministre et le ministre
de l'intérieur qui se rendront à avignon
cet après midi pour un hommage à éric
masson ce policier tué donc
mercredi dernier un autre hommage avait
eu lieu dimanche le père du policier
avait demandé à ce qu'il n'y ait pas de
récupération politique
vous avez tenu néanmoins à y être
présent dimanche à avignon pour cet
hommage pourquoi parce que j'ai voulu
témoigner par ma présence de ma
solidarité de ma sympathie de ma
fraternité je dire je n'ai jamais assez
de cet argument de la récupération
quand on est un homme politique on n'a
pas le droit d'être un homme triste
un homme qui a du chagrin un homme qui a
de la compassion
un homme fraternelle on n'a pas le droit
moi je revendique le droit d'aller prier
d'aller pleurer d'aller partager mon
chagrin et d'aller surtout manifestée
que je suis un homme solidaire solidaire
de la souffrance de la tristesse du
deuil
un événement en tout cas qui a interrogé
sur qui interroge une nouvelle fois sur
l'état du pays une nouvelle tribune
publiée dans valeurs actuelles par les
militaires alerte injustement encore une
nouvelle fois sur la situation en france
on précise elle est anonyme 1 florence
parly ministre et des armes et dénonce
une grossière machination politique
même constat pour le ministre de
l'intérieur gérald darmanin à regarder
il s'agit de gens anonymes
c'est ça le courage d'être anonyme
quelle drôle de société courageuse que
celle qui donne la parole à des anonymes
on se croirait sur les réseaux sociaux
je crois savoir que quand on est
militaire on ne fait ce genre de chose
en cachette à la petite semaine
cet anonymat des militaires vous le
comprenez tout à fait mais quand je vois
quand je vois riquiqui darmanin qui
donne des leçons de courage des
militaires qui ont mené des opérations
de guerre non mais c'est quoi ça ici ici
il se prend pour qui
il ose traiter de lâche
des hommes des femmes peut-être qui ont
mené le combat pour le pays pendant que
lui il est dans son bureau
enfin s'il mériterait d'être souffle
t as raison de garder l'anonymat parce
que sinon ils vont faire l'objet d'une
répression politique d'une répression
politique je dis bien
alors évidemment c'est l'extrême droite
vous savez dans le gard où j'habite il
pleut aujourd'hui je pense que c'est la
faute aussi de l'extrême-droite
voyez-vous quand on la prend cette tribu
il ya deux éléments sur lesquels je
voudrais revenir le premier elle dit il
faut éviter à la france une guerre
civile
vous avez déjà vu des factieux qui
écrivent pour éviter une guerre civile
c'est tout le contraire de factieux et
puis ils lisent aussi nous avons vu de
nos yeux
il porte témoignage il raconte parce
qu'ils ont participé à l'opération
sentinelle qui nous protège ils
racontent ce qu'ils ont vu et ils le
disent et ce qui est ce qui horripile
monsieur darmanin c'est que l'on dise ce
que l'on voit c'est que l'on parle de ce
que l'on entend
c'est que l'on écrive la réalité les
vrais lâche ce sont ceux qui ne veulent
pas voir la réalité et c'est là où on
peut dire que monsieur darmanin est un
lâche
ouvrez lâche politique vous l'avez signé
à vous cette tribune gilbert collard ma
femme l'a signé et moi je vais
l'assigner bien sûr bien sûr bien sûr
alors bien sûr je vous propose en temps
de regarder justement un extrait en ceux
du duo du texte pour ergoter sur la
forme de la tribune de nos aînés au lieu
de reconnaître l'évidence de leur
constat il faut être bien lâche pour
invoquer un devoir de réserve mal
interprétés dans le but de faire taire
des citoyens français
il faut être bien fourbe pour encourager
les cadres dirigeants de l'armée à
prendre position et à s'exposer avant de
les sanctionner rageusement dès qu'ils
écrivent autre chose que des récits de
bataille il faut être bien pervers
qu'est ce que vous pensez des des
sanctions qui ont été prononcées ou
voulu par le chef d'état major des
armées la ministre des armées pour
l'achat n'y a pas encore de sanctions
mais
s'il y avait des sanctions elles se
retournerait contre les contrôles et
sanctionnateur elle se retrouverait
contre les punisse heures parce que ça
aurait un effet dévastateur dans
l'opinion publique
la lal la france ne comprendraient pas
que l'on puisse sanctionner des
militaires qui ont le courage de dire ce
que chacun d'entre nous sauf à être
atteints de cécité morale vois ça serait
à mon avis très mal perçue très mal vécu
qu'une sanctions interviennent contre
des militaires qui ont fait qu'un acte
de liberté d'expression alors on dit
l'armée doit être la grande muette
m'enfin quand même bon si si les
lanceurs d'alert ne lance pas l' alerte
quand ils sont en première ligne qui
lancera la merde c'est l'époque des
lanceurs d'alert et quand on a des
lanceurs d'alert qui nous préviennent
que tout risque de basculer on les
poursuivrait alors l'immigration elle
souvent dénoncé par votre parti a entre
autres à comme l'une des principales
causes de l'insécurité ambiante dans le
pays
elle voyait à ce sujet la proposition de
l'ex ministre michel barnier
je pense qu'il faut décider dans ce pays
un moratoire en matière d'immigration il
faut prendre le temps de vérifier
d'évaluer le cas échéant de changer de
procédure les pratiques de faire le
point évidemment on va toujours
accueillir des étudiants c'est une des
forces des universités françaises
il y a toujours la question du droit
d'asile que nous devons respecter alors
un moratoire en matière d'immigration
proposé par michel barnier
vous soutenez on imagine cette
proposition est un pickpocket
c'est un pickpocket c'est une idée que
nous développons depuis des années je
vous rappelle être intervenu à
l'assemblée quand j'étais député
national du gard pour demander qu'il y
ait notamment en matière de
droit d'asile des contrôles faits avant
l'entrée sur le territoire qu'on était d
espèce de sas juridique de contrôle pour
s'assurer que la personne était bien
habilité à demander l'asile
je m'étais fait insulter mais insulter
je crois que c'est monsieur cazeneuve
qui était monté sur ces petits mollets
pour me répondre et il m'avait traité de
traiter de fasciste vos favoris comme
d'habitude quoi bon et maintenant et
maintenant comme dit la chanson
vla qui reprennent nos idées claires là
ils deviennent très très fréquentables
très fréquentables c'est c'est quand
même la signature du manque de courage
de tous ces gens là de ne pas avoir osé
dire au moment où il fallait le dire
parce que c'était le moment on pouvait
encore peut-être avoir un impuissant
contrôles sur l'immigration
ils n'ont pas osé le dire et maintenant
que que nous sommes arrivés à un point
de maturation peut-être même tardive ils
le disent
quel beau courage alors il reste un
petit peu de temps gilbert collard
peut-être un mot sur la situation
sanitaire l'optimisme du gouvernement
nous touchons au but 1 selon jean castex
c'est le cas selon vous on est en train
de s'en sortir c'est ce que vous
observez assez miraculeux ce qui se
passe c'est miraculeux voilà ce que je
vous dise
hier tout allait mal avant-hier tout
allait bien avant-hier avant-hier tout
allait mal
aujourd'hui tout va bien de quoi demain
sera-t-il fait c'est un gouvernement qui
est atteint de météorologie sanitaires
on a l'impression que c'est en fonction
des circonstances politiques de l'adra
delà de la circonstance des sensibilités
qu'il prend ses décisions
je ne crois pas du tout à la réalité
objective de ce qu'il nous dit je crois
hélas je peux le comprendre pour être
objectif qu'il a la sensation que la
pression est de plus en plus intenable
et qu'il faut la relâcher sinon le
le peuple va se se révolter à et que
donc il faut virus ont pas déverrouiller
voilà mais je n'ai aucune certitude dans
la parole politique telle qu'elle est
articulé aujourd'hui merci gilbert
collard d'avoir accepté notre invitation
dans la matinale de rtl france je le
rappelle mais le député européen du
rassemblement national